[Music]
so let's talk those tell me about a
little bit about the game the game Lobos
is an action-adventure RPG with emphasis
on player exploration of em challenging
moment as we were talking about earlier
guys but it's not forgiving no we want
you to actually get a chance to explore
the world she does to get what was is
all about the experience that you get
while traversing the last semi open
world Isis yes very vibrant and barian
world at the other as I'm looking at the
game it looks fantastic
or the art style looks great what engine
are using wood
again Judy I
ulcers won't okay Wow
impressive impressive so let's get down
to much basics of already obviously you
don't add a to flame right now so let's
get down to basics
and that seemed like a safe day all
right we got it fake boy
so this is a safe point
okay okay
okay
gosh this looks really
[Music]
okay pretty interesting so but not this
time I describe this ambush mechanic but
if that people are attacking while you
rest
and getting that work right now
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
there
that is okay
those are questionnaire yeah get on oh
you'll have to press left or right - one
more time
you chose
so you have that freedom you're not
restricted almost like a
[Music]
so dungeoneering the game now what was
your question Eddie got a question I
wanted to kill my children took it up
dance you have never mind that answer
what's the mechanic on the Dodge can you
hide in like Paul Brown not in this area
know that me if there was high grass
well there was a game where you could
actually sneak up on enemies but that's
not in this first but it's dead look
there's no fast bets as well
[Music]
Gettys get pollution across Paris
the provisions I've got a little
business now how far along is it
currently in development always getting
close to release
[Music]
over eight hours now on any difficulty
understand this currently right now is
running on what
piecing it
my question to you know what about
scaling down to the
what sacrifice had to be made
[Music]
Wow listen that is impressive
the goal is so had it matches questions
any more question I just asked you
deserve all
therefore that looks a bit more style
uses arson attack he wants to do okay
this game it decay of logos has boss
encounters one of the main muscles very
well let's see it was actually one of
the main boss eight that
over there or you can do
therefore those guys are good supper
now
so that is dis considered but
Oh
so once it gets through this he'll be
able to see that we might be able to see
that boy that boy
[Music]
are you liking it I like the water
[Music]
to the store
there we go this is what how did you win
for
[Music]
now
it really doesn't miss the game papa
the question is in reference to that
story how do you guys implementing a
nowadays these are going to be Civic
cinematics
this
should we get that little personal voice
action right I'll be gone or damn
[Music]
consider your elevated air
now we're getting close to this oh yeah
[Music]
yeah this is definitely going
alright looks like Jerry Anna Rico is a
cinematic
okay love mr. Witherspoon
okay
in a crass tune in next week develop
don't well you can see it in action in
our website there's the video there
actually it is the end of the demo
whatever demo love fantastic man huge
fans of this game how to eye on it for
some time decay of logos